[Music]
the single most powerful asset we have
is our mind if it is trained well it can
create enormous wealth in what seems to
be an instant
[Music]
find the game where you can win and then
commit your life to playing it and play
to win
[Music]
successful people ask questions they
seek new teachers they're always
learning
the problem with having a job is that it
gets in the way of getting rich
[Music]
start small and dream big
if you want to be financially free you
need to become a different person than
the one you are today and let go of
whatever has held you back in the past
the philosophy of the rich and the poor
is this the rich invest their money and
spend what is left the poor spend their
money and invest what is left
sight is what you see with your eyes
vision is what you see with your mind
never say you cannot afford something
that is a poor man's attitude ask how
you can afford it
your future is created by what you do
today not tomorrow
the more I risk being rejected the
better my chances are of being accepted
one of the most stupid things to do is
to pretend you are smart when you
pretend to be smart you are at the
height of stupidity
find out where you are where you want to
be and build a plan to get there
[Music]
most people want everyone else in the
World to Change let me tell you it's
easier to change yourself than to change
everyone else
people who dream small dreams continue
to live as small people
richest people in the world build
networks everyone else is trained to
look for work
there are those who make things happen
there are those who watch things happen
and there are those who say what
happened
skills not theories make you rich
foreign
losers quit when they fail
winners fail until they succeed
when you come to the boundaries of what
you know it is time to make some
mistakes
the ability to sell is the number one
skill in business
if you cannot sell don't bother thinking
about becoming a business owner
most people are too lazy to think
instead of learning something new they
think the same thought day after day
[Music]
education is cheap experience is
expensive
there are no mistakes in life just
learning opportunities
the love of money is not the root of all
evil the lack of money is the root of
all evil
when you are forced to think you expand
your mental capacity when you expand
your mental capacity your wealth
increases
[Music]
making mistakes isn't enough to become
great you must also admit the mistake
and then learn how to turn the mistake
into an advantage
in today's rapidly changing world the
people who are not taking risks are the
real Risk Takers
excuses are a dime a dozen that's why
the poor have so many of them
people need to wake up and realize that
life doesn't wait for you if you want
something get up and go after it
if you want to be rich serve more people
it is easy to stay the same it is not
easy to change most people choose to
stay the same all their lives
[Music]
it does not take money to make money
[Music]
a mistake is a signal that it is time to
learn something new something you didn't
know before
[Music]
there are no bad business and investment
opportunities but there are bad
entrepreneurs and investors
if you want to go somewhere it is best
to find someone who has already been
there foreign
teacher we learn the most about
ourselves when we fail
so don't be afraid of failing failing is
part of the process of success
you cannot have success without failure
The Wealthy by luxuries last while the
poor and middle class tend to buy
luxuries first why emotional discipline
or lack of it
when times are bad is when the real
entrepreneurs emerge
sometimes you win sometimes you learn
you get one life live it in a way that
inspires someone
when I started my last business I didn't
receive a paycheck for 13 months
the average person can't handle that
pressure
[Music]
getting rich begins with the right
mindset the right words and the right
plan
[Music]
sometimes what is right for you at the
beginning of your life
is not right for you at the end of your
life
business is like a wheelbarrow nothing
happens until you start pushing
business and investing are team sports
the hardest part of Change is Going
Through The Unknown
Financial struggle is often the direct
result of people working all their lives
for someone else
being an entrepreneur is simply going
from one mistake to the next you must
have the fortitude to continue
[Music]
the most life-destroying word of all is
this tomorrow
intelligence solves problems and
produces money money without Financial
intelligence is money soon gone
[Music]
the size of your success is measured by
the strength of your desire
the size of your dream and how you
handle disappointment along the way
foreign
the most successful people are Mavericks
who aren't afraid to ask why
especially when everyone thinks it's
obvious
hoping drains your energy action creates
energy
[Music]
the more a person seeks security the
more that person gives up control over
his life
and tell you the risk an entrepreneur
can see the reward
the only difference between a rich
person and a poor person is how they use
their time
your choices decide your fate
take the time to make the right ones if
you make a mistake that's fine learn
from it and don't make it again
money is really just an idea
talk is cheap learn to listen with your
eyes actions do speak louder than words
watch what a person does more than what
he says
the moment you make passive income and
portfolio income a part of your life
your life will change
those words will become flesh
if you realize that you're the problem
then you can change yourself learn
something and grow wiser don't blame
other people for your problems
workers work hard enough to not be fired
and business owners pay just enough so
that workers won't quit
without a strong reason or purpose
anything in life is hard
winners are not afraid of losing losers
are failure is part of the process of
success
people who avoid failure Miss success
foreign if you want to be rich you need
to develop your vision
you must be standing on the Edge of Time
gazing into the future
[Music]
the fear of being different prevents
most people from seeking new ways to
solve their problems
don't be addicted to money work to learn
don't work for money work for knowledge
the trouble with school is they give you
the answer then they give you the exam
that's not life
[Music]
it's more important to grow your income
than to cut your expenses
it's more important to grow your spirit
than to cut your dreams
the most successful people in life are
the ones who ask questions they're
always learning they're always growing
they're always pushy
complaining about your current position
in life is worthless have a spine to do
something about it instead
in the real world the smartest people
are those who make mistakes and learn in
school the smartest people don't make
mistakes
it's not what you say out of your mouth
that determines your life it's what you
whisper to yourself
foreign
it's easier to stand on the sidelines
criticize and say why you shouldn't do
something
the sidelines are crowded get in the
game
most people in their drive to get rich
are trying to build an Empire State
Building on a six-inch slab
more money seldom solve someone's money
problems
the more we know about the power of
money the more distant we grow from our
teachers and our classmates
[Music]
an asset puts money in my pocket a
liability takes money out of my pocket
a person can be highly educated
professionally successful and
financially illiterate
by not understanding money the vast
majority of people allow its awesome
power to control them
[Music]
an intelligent person hires people who
are more intelligent than he is
I'd rather welcome change than cling to
the Past
[Music]
the greater your financial intelligence
the easier it is to tell whether a deal
is good
if you're still doing what Mommy and
Daddy said for you to do go to school
get a job save money you're losing
foreign
[Music]